[Musik]
verteidigen und wären und die haben
natürlich auch geübt
[Musik]
für euch ist aber für mich alleine durch
diesen Konflikt ist die Übung jetzt eine
ganz andere durch den Konflikt druckt
das dass man Blitzerdaten haben die sind
auch das Licht ich persönlich nehmen bei
mir auch war dass ich die Motivation die
Einstellung um 180 Grad gedreht hat weil
ich einfach sehe dass die reale
Bedrohungen wirklich vorhanden sind
Information
und die haben tatsächlich
bei mir im Bekanntenkreis waren jetzt
erstaunlicherweise einige Leute die
vorher absolut pazifistisch eingestellt
waren im Sinne überhaupt kein
Kriegsgerät bedeutet überhaupt kein
Krieg die ihre Meinung jetzt sehr stark
geändert haben
[Musik]
können beim Militär gibt es das
Sprichwort das heißt kämpfen können und
nicht kämpfen zu müssen
[Musik]
die war froh und sein gab weil Kim es
dann einmal
die passen auf uns und da war Schaukel
was da stark Seehaus wo drauf verlassen
kannst für uns ist das ganz normal wir
sind die ganze Zeit in der jeder von uns
auf der Welt ist und in Österreich lebt
wir leben in einer Demokratie jeder darf
sagen was er für richtig hält ja jeder
hat er freie Meinung es ist bei uns
möglich und das ist auch das ist auch
wert also das ist riesen riesen Luxus
wir haben und das Keller beschützt